für diese Kinder ist Krieg schon längst
kein Spiel mehr Familie sachakian ist
aus berkarabach geflohen jetzt Tarren
sie im armenischen Grenzort gohres aus
sie sind Armenia sowie fast alle
Einwohner dieser kleinen Region im
Kaukasus in der Nacht zum 19 September
als Aserbaidschan ihre Heimat Angriff
verließen sie überstürzt ihr zu Hause
sie sind zu 13 und wohnen nun zusammen
in zwei Hotelzimmern
wir haben nichts mitgenommen wir haben
unser Haus zurückgelassen unsere Tiere
Hühner Schafe Kühe Gänse Enten in ihren
stellen denn es war Abend wir haben den
Geburtstag meiner Enkelin gefeiert die
Tiere waren schon eingesperrt
werden diese Tiere dort sterben oder
werden sie leben ich weiß nicht
einmal Fotos sind ihnen geblieben
Jahrzehnte lang lebten sie in
Bergkarabach nun werden sie vermutlich
nie zurückkehren
sowie zehntausende es ist ein Massen
Exodus nachdem Aserbaidschan angegriffen
hat und danach noch tagelang die
Fluchtwege blockierte
abgeriegelt war die Region schon Monate
lang kaum Lebensmittel Medikamente
Benzin kamen rein kaum Menschen raus
dann der Angriff und die Angst vor einem
Leben unter aserbaidschanischer
Herrschaft
die Menschen die in diesen Tagen in
Gores ankommen haben Angst unterdrückt
zu werden Angst vor Gewalt durch
aserbaidschanische Soldaten
so sehr dass sie überstürzt geflohen
sind manche nur mit dem was sie schnell
greifen konnten oder was ihnen
unverzichtbar erschienen
en
wir bringen auch die Leiche unseres
Neffen der Sohn meiner Schwester
warum sollten wir ihn dort lassen viele
haben ihre Söhne begraben aber wir
bringen unsere mit damit er in unserer
Nähe ist und sein Grab nicht verwüstet
oder geschändet wird
wir haben keine Möglichkeit dort zu
leben
es ist unser Heimatland
[Musik]
aber sie reißen es schamlos an sich
Grausamkeiten gab es in der
Vergangenheit immer wieder von beiden
Seiten Armenia und Aserbaidschaner sind
Erzfeinde
der Kaukasus seit Jahrzehnten ein
Pulverfass von der bergigen Grenzregion
bis zur Hauptstadt sind es gerade mal
250 km
ein paar Tage zuvor sind wir in Eriwan
wir besuchen das Hauptquartier einer
paramilitärischen Miliz es sind
Zivilisten die sich hier an der Waffe
ausbilden lassen
Angina haben wir vor knapp einem Jahr
schon mal getroffen als sie selbst diese
Ausbildung machte sie arbeitet für die
Miliz seit dem aserbaidschanischen
Angriff auf berkerer Bach habe sich auch
hier einiges verändert erzählt sie
es sind mehr Leute hierher gekommen
vorher haben hier kleine Gruppen
trainiert zehn Leute etwa jetzt sind es
Gruppen von teilweise 300 freiwilligen
armenisches Territorium angreift ist
immer da nach dem Krieg 2020 dachten wir
dass sie angreifen würden jetzt ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit eines Angriffs noch
höher
hier sind Sie sicher dass Aserbaidschan
nicht Halt macht in Bergkarabach sondern
bald auch das armenische Kernland
angreifen wird denn armenien ist der
Machtkampf um den Kaukasus auf
verlorenem Posten
die Akteure dieses macht Kampfs auf der
einen Seite alias der autokratische
Präsident von Aserbaidschan politisch
und militärisch unterstützt von Erdogan
dem Präsidenten der Türkei sie wollen
schon lange mehr als Berka Rabach eine
Landverbindung zwischen ihren Ländern
die mitten durch Armenien führen würde
[Musik]
auf der anderen Seite Armeniens premier
paschinian Regierungschef einer
Demokratie der sich zwar annähern will
an den Westen aber abhängig ist von
Russland
militärisch wirtschaftlich Putin aber
schreitet nicht ein als Aserbaidschan
der Karabach angreift
die Armenier sind wütend wütend auf
Russland dass sie allein gelassen hat
wütend vor allem auf die eigene
Regierung die bergkara Bach aufgegeben
hat immer wieder protestieren sie in
Eriwan Nacht und Tag
Appelle auch an die Welt die wegschaut
arzach so nennen sie hier berkarabach
Vertreibung Genozid ethnische
Säuberungen so nennen sie das was dort
passiert
zurück an der Grenze immermenischen
Gores das sind zwischen ein einziges
großes flüchtlingskamp geworden ist
jeden Tag werden es mehr Menschen
mittendrin Familie zachakian für die
Kinder ein Moment durchzuatmen aber auch
die jüngsten wissen genau wer ihr Feind
ist
zurückkehren nein wieso nicht
es ist schlimm dort
[Musik]
wie es für sie in Armenien weitergeht
wissen sie noch nicht
irgendwo wo ist ein Haus für uns gibt
wir können für uns selbst haben von
Beruf bin ich Chemikerin aber es wäre
auch in Ordnung für mich Böden zu
fliegen stellen Sie uns einfach ein Haus
zur Verfügung
erstmal harren sie in gohres aus
zumindest raus aus der Hölle zu der
Bergkarabach für sie geworden ist
so wie für zehntausende Armenier
[Musik]